hey folks
how you all doing
all right you enjoying the complimentary
food and drinks and everything
it's great to see so many of your faces
here it makes me so happy i spoke at ndc
last year which you may or may not
remember was just
all virtual so i spent the whole i spent
an hour just talking to a camera which
believe me it's not the best kind of way
you don't get the most sort of feedback
from the audience so having seen so many
places here makes me really
really excited now just a heads up i
might ask you a one point maybe two for
a little bit of audience participation
now this is not dangerous
you feel free to join along don't do it
if you don't want to it's only good fun
anyway anyway welcome to this little
session on building webassembly games
with rust
how we move video games from consoles
and on your local machine and into the
browser
so
let's start with a little sort of
outline for what we're going to do today
uh
the duration here is
actually about correct we'll be spending
about 45 minutes with me just talking
you listening at any point if you've got
any questions feel free to
just shout out raise your hand or
whatever and i'll try and answer them as
we go along
there's really no like strict schedule
we have to follow
um anyway the talk is divided roughly
into three parts one is how do you even
get started like what are the tools that
we want to use when building these games
the second is when we how when we put it
together how do you actually build the
game what sort of adjustments you need
to make to build a game for the web
instead of for
a
for any well a native platform i would
say
and finally
when it's actually working and it builds
for the web and it plays
what sort of concerns do you need to
have in mind when building for a
platform such as the web how is it
different from native and what you need
to optimize for
anyway let's start with a little
introduction hey folks i'm thomas
hartman
i'm currently a developer community
manager sort of developer relations ish
very vague i don't know what i'm doing
my boss doesn't know what i'm doing it's
pretty good
uh i used to be a full stack-ish
developer like i've been everywhere i've
done a bit of front-line i've done a bit
of back-end not an expert at anything
but i'm just really really curious i
really like playing around and learning
new stuff
now i'm a rust enthusiast or a station
as we like to call ourselves and i
co-host the rust oslo meetup group
so when it was time to write a game for
the web it was pretty obvious that yeah
i'd go for rust now i don't have a very
impressive cv at all i haven't built
massive projects i don't maintain curl
or anything like that i just
like to learn i'm curious and i like
playing with things
and more than that i love video games
and i have ever since i was a kid
now
when i was a kid i was my mother's first
child right and she was quite
conservative and she didn't really want
to let me watch tv for too long or play
games or do anything
so i always had go to my friends places
to play right and i was always super
excited but then
lucky stroke
i got really ill
that meant that i had to stay home for
like weeks
and my mother was sort of scratching her
thinking well
how am i going to entertain this kid i
got to get some work done as well
turns out the
solution is a nintendo 64.
i was super excited right so i spent a
couple of weeks
much like this kid yeah uh just playing
super mario 64 and banjo-kazooie and
just loving everything and since then
like i've loved games
all the while
sadly as i'm sure a lot of you can
relate to once you grow up and you start
a job you don't get as much time to play
as you want to but that doesn't mean
that my mind doesn't immediately go ah
games games this is cool can we do
anything with games for this
so
that's why i thought yeah
let's write a game oh by the way i just
realized you can see my address bar and
stuff i'm really sorry about that but i
haven't found a way to both show full
screen the pronunciation and my speaker
notes so you'll just have to live with
it it's fine
anyway
yeah so writing a game
for the browser using rust
there's a lot of moving parts and it
could be really really difficult but
um i had hoped it would be harder
because it's actually not it's
surprisingly easy
and when i found that out i figured oh
i gotta think of something else now
to talk about for an hour right i gotta
have something to show
and luckily
i do
um
so just sit along and enjoy it
first off why
why even write games of the browser
right like why not just deal with native
games aren't they great i mean sure they
are and they run they're optimized for
the various platforms
but that's the thing there are various
platforms they run on multiple separate
instances
that means like if you're on a computer
you need to download the right file for
your operating system if you're on a
phone you need to get the right file for
that and everything and i'm sure if
you've played games you can also relate
to the fact that oh you might have this
dll installer you need to link something
or things just stop working
with the browser you've got one target
and this target runs on pretty much all
modern systems so it's very easy right
you go oh well you put it here everyone
can get hold of it they don't need to
download anything it's just there right
in the browser
so it's a great way to sort of make
things
accessible and make let people see what
you're working on without having to
download stuff
and spend a lot of time getting set up
that's what makes it really exciting to
me now
how do we get started with this as i
said
i had a goal i wanted a game
in a browser
that means
probably webassembly you could do just
javascript and play with the canvas and
all that stuff but it's more fun if it's
web assembly
and second
as i said i love rust
naturally
let's try and put them together
now i also said specified this talk
does not require any sort of rust
knowledge so don't worry we're not going
to dive deep into like the internals of
how this function works and all that
stuff it's all mostly pretty high level
there's some optimization stuff later
that gets a bit into the weeds
but just hang out and she'll be fine
anyway
let's talk about
rust because i mean why
why would you choose rust and rust
basket ferrous is probably a bit hurt
that you would even ask
but for me it was never really a
question so
let's talk about rust
rust is a systems programming language
is what they bill it as but it's
basically just a program language that
looks a lot like c
it's got the c style structure that
you're probably familiar with from c
from javascript and from all of that
stuff
um now this isn't a learner's talk so
this is probably the most we're going to
see syntax wise so just so you know it's
something you're familiar with
um
rust is a compiled language much like
again c-sharp and java
so as opposed to javascript and python
that are interpreted that means you
build it once you get a binary and you
can distribute the binary you don't need
to distribute the source files right
next
there's no runtime and there's no
garbage collector this is more similar
to c and c plus plus
where you need to do manual memory
allocations to make sure you free and
allocate the memory you need
rust does this slightly differently
it has something called the borrowed
checker
which means at compile time uh when you
build everything like in your source
files you have to declare and make sure
that everything works that the memory is
freed and all that stuff but
russ does it for you just make sure that
it doesn't compile unless things work
so this stuff so you get in memory leaks
and is stops a whole host of bugs so
it's really really useful for that
um it's also fast and memory efficient
and this goes back to what i was saying
in terms of not having a runtime not
being garbage collected right so like c
and staples plus you get really really
high performance and you don't have
these slow downs when you need to sort
of collect all the garbage or start up
the runtime so you get away from that
now
what about me why do i like ross because
i mean this is great language wise
but what is it about the language that
draws me to it i mean sure performance
is good it's all well and good but
i don't really encounter that a lot when
i just do my own recording in my spare
time right why do i need to worry about
that um
so i think one of my favorite things is
rust's type system which is really
really expressive and it's actually
touring complete
you can build a program with types such
that it doesn't compile
because it just never finishes the
halting problem right
or i mean in
the compilation will start because of a
stack overflow error at the end or a
recursion depth error
but it's really really powerful it's a
lot more similar to stuff like haskell
to ocamel than it is to c-sharp and java
and this lets you model a lot of stuff
very elegantly
um it's ergonomic in the way yeah it's
low level like c like c plus plus but
it's also got a lot of functions
and functionality set up so that it's
sort of like it feels like python
and a lot of it it's just got clear
functions it's easy to do what you want
to do
the community is warm and welcoming it
is one or probably the most welcoming
community that i know
and it's very supportive and everyone is
very welcome
um it's challenging but in a good way i
mentioned borrowjack earlier
once you start working with it like it's
kind of hard to get going because it'll
tell you oh you can't do this you can't
do that or hey you're free here but
using it again here
and at first that can be a bit of a
grind but once you get used to it and
once you learn why and how it works it's
actually really really fun
in a kind of a weird fun way right but
also it's uh it's
it helps you think about how you
structure your programs in general not
just in rust
and of course the cute little crab
ferris as the mascot
so
we've gone over most of this now so why
would rust be a good tool for video game
development well obviously
if it's faster memory efficient that's
great for a game that means you can draw
more pixels on the screen it means you
can fit more things in a game
that is exactly what you want
it's also
not garbage collected so that means you
don't get these sudden slowdowns when it
has to sort of collect all the threads
and collect all the loose objects you
get away from that completely
and finally
it compiles two asm really really well
there's a lot of tools in the web and
rusty ecosystem that just put things
together
so
making that
leap from a native binary to web binary
is pretty simple
so
web assembly then okay cool we know what
ross is what is web assembly
um i was writing this talk right and i
thought hey okay so this is website's
logo
it's purple and it says
it's
purple and it says
now i don't know if nintendo had
anything to do with this at all but i
also can't say they didn't so
take that for what you will
anyway webassembly or wasm
is an assembly like language for the web
um it has a it's been designed
to complement the work alongside
javascript not necessarily replace it
although a lot of people thought it
would in the beginning
that's not really what it's meant to do
it's fast uh it runs with
near-native performance as they call it
basically it runs faster than javascript
it's great to use for intensive
computations
and it runs in pretty much all the
modern browsers so all the big four like
chrome firefox
safari and
edge even before it was edgium so even
the old edge does it
uh and also there's something called
lazy or webassembly systems interface i
think which allows you to run whether
somebody everywhere even outside the
browser you'll need a runtime for it
but it makes it really really exciting
uh because you can use that to sort of
numb containerized applications because
website has a really strict security
protocol so it's great for saying oh you
don't get access to this and this and
that
so
not that i'm the expert here but it
sounds as if it might um actually
be useful in the similar way that
containers are used today
um as i said it was implemented in four
major browsers in 2017 that's four years
ago it's been around for a while it's
just
you've probably used it you just haven't
realized uh and finally
in 2019 it became a w3c recommendation
that puts it on the same level as
javascript html and css as language of
the web it is an officially a big thing
so what's it look like
um this
is a factorial function in c you don't
need to understand it it's just
that's what it looks like now in
webassembly as i said webassembly is a
assembly-like language with a compact
binary format
so a dot wasn't file
looks like this
now i don't know about you
but this doesn't look like anything to
me it's just
a bunch of numbers put all together it
doesn't really help in any way
but
luckily websimply has another format as
well
you've got webassembly and you got
webassembly text and the fun thing is
because they've got different extensions
so webassembly is dot wasm
webassembly text is
what
yeah
again don't know if that's on purpose or
a joke or whatnot but it's actually
called what
and web assembly text is a lot more
readable
uh because it looks like this
which sort of
kind of looks like any sort of function
you might or any if you squint it sort
of looks like a language
but also uh
you can also make it look like this if
you're into lips this is great
because it's just a bunch of s
expressions
now these two forms are equivalent
and it's just a different way of writing
the same thing one is easy to read
one is probably easier to edit depending
on how you
like editing stuff
final part then now that we've got rust
and we've got webassembly is the game
engine
what
do we do with this one
uh here's my choices the ones i had
amethyst
bevy
or whiteboard from scratch now this
isn't quite up to date the way it is now
amethyst is or was a game engine in rust
it has since
stopped working on the game engine and
started just
helping the community in the game engine
community itself
bevvy is still active
uh and a good choice uh right from
scratch is an option
but not for me uh i would not know even
where to start or and
i mean this took a while this thing but
imagine just how much longer would it
take if i had a written whole engine
so nah dropped that and decided to go
with
betty because
it was a
well it's it's gotten so much attention
in the system lately
there are also other choices i just
wasn't really aware of them
now
in part the reason i chose baby is
because i got a good friend who just
won't shut up about it it's great i love
him and
he's got me really into the idea of this
engine
bevi according to themselves is a
refreshingly simple data-driven game
engine built in rust
it's based on an ecs or entity component
system again we're not going to delve
into what that means for a game
and i probably couldn't explain it well
enough if i tried
so but it's different from how say
unreal works i think or a number of
other engines that usually use a scene
graph and instead you've got
you know what never mind
it's also as opposed to other engines
that i've worked with
there's no graphical editor previously
when i've made games i've used unity
i've used a bit of unreal and they have
this nice like scene and drive where you
can place things in and you can move
them around and shift them up and down
none of that everything
is straight from your editor
which is fine but it's a different
workflow right you got to think about
things in a very different way
now about wasm support
in bevi 0.5 which is the current version
you need a plugin
but it's very simple you add a plugin
and it compiles for wasn't easy in
betwee 0.6 it will be built in
which is really quite exciting and
really just elevates wisdom as like a
proper target
so
we've got the tools
part time for part two there's just no
way this will work right
uh and we'll start by or talking about
writing the actual game
because that's supposed to be the fun
part right this is why i did this i
could write a game
um
full disclosure i didn't
the thing is i had
massive plans
um
and i applied for nbc right
and then they accepted two of my talks
and not just one
and suddenly i had to get a lot of
done like oh can i do
this can i do this
and also when you're writing a game or
just in general you might know
troubleshooting
that's time consuming you spend a lot of
time trying to figure out why it doesn't
work
so um
i originally wanted to look really cool
and really slick and present like a
maths puzzle game
i took a course in discrete mathematics
this spring i thought ah this is awesome
so i wanted to create like
generate graphs and ask you to find like
a yellow path around it or euler path
sorry wow
or
like oh you can use modular arithmetic
to sort of figure out what's going on
there
didn't happen didn't happen um so i
could think okay well let's
simplify it we'll make a flappy bird
clone that's easy right it's
one thing that bob's up and down an
environment that passes forth
should be easy uh
yeah
that also takes time it didn't happen
so i ended up using an example from bevy
that they sort of ship with there
and it's breakout
it's breakout
hey
thank you have yourself some extra
complimentary like coffee on me whatever
but it looks like this
and it works
so let's see what you need to do to
actually make it compile for webassembly
instead of
as a native binary
because originally the example
targets
native platforms so let's look at the
little bits that you need to add
to make it run on the web
um parts of it relate to
the limitations of the platform now some
of these aren't really necessarily
relevant for the game because breakout
is simple enough there isn't any
multi-threading going on
but webassembly does not support
multi-threading as of now
also fun thing
bevy's default renderer is web gpu
but no browsers support web gpu as of
now
so
when compiling for native you use web
gpu when you compile for the web you use
a webgl too
engine instead
it's just a little plug that you gotta
switch out it's not a big thing
the built-in audio system doesn't work
again doesn't really matter for breakout
there's no sound
uh but there are plugins you can get
that just dropping replacements and work
and finally if you want to control it
using a gamepad joystick or controller
that's not supported on the web sadly
but
now let's look at the bits you need to
actually change in your
files both source files and package
files
and okay so the first one
this is part of a cargo.tml file which
in rust is sort of like a package.json
or whatever it's where you describe the
package and all the dependencies right
in the original breakout game
this was all there was i mean there was
a section saying who's the author and
why is it but the only thing in there
that wasn't metadata is this
dependency on devi now
when we
change the wasm
it kind of expands a little bit now this
looks really really scary but it's not
as bad as it seems and most of this is
actually just saying what was saying oh
about the gpu web gpu and the webgl
you'll notice that at the top it says
features and then it says all the
default features and then it splits into
native and web and this is how you tell
it how to compile the basic various
platforms
so here we say uh well okay use a
different renderer when building for
native
and for the web for everything else use
the default ones
and finally because we
also added a new crate the right package
if you will the
webgl renderer we need to add that too
pretty simple
but it's kind of intimidating because it
went from one line to like 20.
next up here is a main function again
we're not going to delve into what a or
how this works really
but this is the main function this
this one function has every change i had
to make to make it compile and run on
the web
and is this fit
that's literally all i had to change it
says okay when we're compiling for the
webassembly target architecture
add the webgl to plugin
as i said that's the only change you
really had to make super easy
now this is scary
this is cargo make this is a make file
like format
so it's sort of inspired by
i guess make file you use for c
whatever so it's a build system that's
split into tasks
um
it is actually pretty good but this
isn't something you see in most rust
projects so it wasn't really something i
was familiar with how to use
now i'm going to run over to
this here side because i can point at
the screen is that okay
great all right oh
what is a bit weird but yeah so
um and it's great it runs and it builds
and it's in the browser
now enjoy this gif of anakin skywalker a
bit longer while i have another sip
so
when you have a game that you're
supposed to play in the browser
let's talk about what you need to sort
of build
and bundle it because i mean one thing
is the binary right you can create a
binary but how do you distribute it and
how do you put it on a web page and also
what sort of
things do you need to think about
when you build it like what do you
optimize for on the web is it different
from native or how does it change
anyway
the first thing we need to do to wire
everything together is an html file it's
supposed to go in the web it needs file
right
and it's really pretty simple all it
takes is this little block
of javascript which imports and starts
the game
now this file is sort of included it's
that's part of the template for building
for the web
and so it's in the repository and
automatically it's built in
to like your distribution
and once you do that
it just works you get a blank page you
get the game so there's nothing great on
the page it's literally just a blank
page but at least it runs right at least
it's a game
now let's look at the file because it
says it import init from target wasn't
js right
and this file
is over a thousand lines of magic
numbers of
obfuscated lines and names and it's
really sort of nasty you really don't
want to write that yourself
luckily you don't have to it's generated
for you
by wasn't binding and this is the same
crate that we saw the arrow with earlier
where i had the dependency mismatch
same crate now this crate is really a
life saver
because this is what sort of enables
rust to talk to
javascript in and out and to bind things
properly thus they're buying gen
again according to them it's rust
library and the cli that facilitates
high
level interactions between wasn't
modules and javascript
it's part of the boston webassembly egg
system the thing about this is
webassembly by default really has
floats
is it and u32s and that's all the types
you get
that's a bit hard to work with if you're
used to working with data structures and
you're used to working with like
anything
i mean anything except for just like
numbers
then
you want something to not have to think
about what number is this
luckily wasn't binding lets you use the
same types the same structs the same
objects that you're used to
in your codings you don't need to worry
about it it's great it also
lets you import stuff from javascript
into rust so you can call javascript
modules from your rust code
super
uh and you can even like do stuff like
manipulate the dom and all that it's
really really interesting how they've
done it it's
necessary
another cool thing if you do typescript
it automatically generates bindings so
all in all great
hey fan
now
so you use that and then
when it runs it's time to make the
package small
and this is where
the web differs from native right
because when you compile natively you
usually want optimize speed you want
things to run as fast as possible you
want to render as much as you can you
want to make it run run run run
but on the web
a larger size means it'll take longer to
download which means it'll take longer
before you see anything before they can
interact with it so you probably want to
change your target and say actually
i want a small binary it's okay if it
runs a little bit slower
just make it a bit smaller
um obviously that's a trade-off and
you've got to figure out okay well
what's right for my game or what do you
want to optimize for because maybe
sometimes you can
you have your users and you know if
they're happy to wait half an hour every
game to download
but usually you probably don't you
probably want them running as soon as
possible but obviously in the end you
need to optimize for
or you need to measure and optimize
what's right for you
now measurement is important
because otherwise how do you know
what works and what doesn't
let's actually look at this because
originally when i built it
just no optimizations know anything just
in release mode
it's 12.1 megabytes
that's a pretty large download that can
take a little bit of time
especially on slower networks right so
it can take a while to get that one down
so let's look at some of the tips we can
do some of the tricks
number one and this is where it gets
sort of into the weeds i'll get sort of
into how rust's uh compilation works and
all that but it's not super important
you can do something called link time
optimizations now i'm not a compiler
engineer so this a lot of this is above
my head
but apparently it lets llvm which is the
back end the low-level virtual machine
it lets it inline and prune functions
more often
which for you means you get a smaller
binary and it runs a little bit faster
so this is good
however the trade-off
you get longer compile times it takes a
bit longer to compile
but you get something out of it
the other thing we can do
is to optimize for size
by default lvm optimizes for speed it
wants things to run fast because usually
that's what you want
however we've got two flags change that
they're called the they're called s and
z or z if you will
now z
is more aggressive than s
so it should in theory give you smaller
binaries right
that's usually the case at least so i'm
told but sometimes s yields better
results so again what you've got to do
measure
when compiled with link time
optimization to thin
we saved about a meg that's
fine right i i don't really know what
we're looking for in terms of like how
much we want to save but that doesn't
seem all that impressive
uh when we optimize for size this one's
quite fun z
give us 12.4 megabytes the aggressive
optimization for size made it larger
i
don't know why or what
but that's why it did now using s
it got smaller again and that's good so
s takes it down to about
11.8 and level z takes up to about 12.4
okay cool what if we put them together
can we do both lto thin and
like probably s right
well we'll try z as well and see what's
better
of course we can
when we put them together
the
length of optimization and the s
optimization takes us to 10.4
megabytes uh and the z just takes us to
10.8 so the s is still performing better
but again
saving
one and a half megabyte out of 12 still
doesn't seem very impressive
at that point is it worth it and what do
you got to download at 10 and a half
anyway it's not that much extra to
weight you the extra 10
so
luckily there's more stuff we can do
let's look at post processing
you see
there's a tool called wasmopt which is
a post-processing tool from a package
called binarian or binarian
i don't know how to pronounce that
anyway binary is the compiler and tool
chain infrastructure library for
webassembly and is written in c plus
plus
its aim is to make compiling to
reassembly easy
fast and effective
what it does is that it sort of improves
on llvm's optimizations and makes it
even better again i'm not a compiler
engineer i don't know exactly how it
works all i know is that it does good
stuff for you and it makes your binary
better
so
let's see what happens when we try and
apply this
now we had
the s binary right there was 10.4 this
is both with length optimizations
and
with
the uh
s
optimization it was the smallest one the
two we had right so we apply one's mop
to it and optimize again for s
and we get down point to 6.1
now this is a lot better now we actually
have
we've split the amount of space you need
in two this is great
the other one
was a bit larger remember
but the funny thing is when you run this
with wasmat
it gets even smaller and we go from 12
down to 5.2 now granted that's still
quite a lot of
quite a lot of data to ship
but i'm sure there are websites out
there that ship more javascript than
that so it's probably not the worst
thing in the world at least we've cut
seven out of 12 megs which is pretty
good i'd say
now if this isn't enough for you
you can also run various kinds of code
profiling
and
other sort of tweaks
there is a code profiler called twiggy
which is a size profiling tool for wasm
what it does is it analyzes the call
graph and it lets you see figure out why
a function is called
and if we remove that function how much
space would we actually save in the
binary
and also remove sort of the
other functions that are affected by
this
but we've also got manual interventions
and again
this gets slightly into the weed of how
rust works and compilation but
we'll do it briefly
one avoid string formatting uh obviously
this causes allocations because you
can't know the size of a string
so the less you can do that
the less space you need in the binary
you want to avoid panics
panics are
what
rust doesn't have exceptions
but a panic is when something happens
and
just just throws his hands up it's like
i don't know what to do i don't know
what to do and it just exits
now
the reason why removing panics
work is because to panic or when you
panic you also get a stack trace
you can use a
preprocessor macro that'll stop you from
panicking or when you do panic
you won't get a stack trace and that
means there's less for you to worry
about in the binary
you can avoid allocations as much as
possible
especially in hot code paths this is the
same for any language that has any sort
of allocations the more you allocate the
more time it takes and the more space it
uses
now
by
if you can strip all the allocations
in your binary amazing the roster
allocator takes about i heard 10
kilobytes that means you say 10
kilobytes we've seen now that we've got
five megs 10 kilobytes isn't going to be
too much but like if you're down at that
level he's like i need to get those fine
little bits out do that or
use a different allocator
you can switch allocators and rust to
something called we alloc now this one's
less focus on
having predictable performance but it is
a bit smaller
and this one's fun
in rust you can use trait objects
instead of generics
and without getting too much into it
what this means
when you use a generic in rust same as
generic in c sharp or whatever
rust actually takes this function and
monomorphizes it in the output that
means one function
gets compiled to however many times it's
called so it's one for each type it's
called with
each one of those so the function say
you call it with five different types
then you get in the binary you get five
different functions
but each use a single type instead so
they're faster they take more space
instead if you use
straight objects you get what's called
dynamic dispatch that means rust figures
out at runtime whether
is this type of that type of that type
it's a bit slower but you get only the
one function so it takes less space
and that's we want and finally
there is a tool called wasm snip i think
this is a really funny name
and what it does is you can annotate a
function and say snip
and then if you know that this function
is not called at runtime it just will be
completely excluded from the binary
as well as all the functions that it
sort of relies on
now i don't know why you would do this
or what sort of use cases it's useful
for i've i've went and checked out the
project seen the readme
that's just what it says and i guess for
some reason if you want to run
probably if you have what's called a
const function you can run it at compile
time in rust
so you can probably remove those if you
know you're not going to use
it which would be useful
now
all that out of the way
this is an important sort of adage from
uh
the bits of optimization
just like how we let time profiling
guide our speed up methods we want to
let size profiling guide our code size
shrinking efforts
fail to do this and you risk wasting
your own time
and well maybe that of your employers
but basically it just means yeah you
spend a lot of time that you won't get
back and it might not really pay off
so
in summary
remember kids
that going from rust to webassembly
is actually easier than you'd think
the main thing is sort of picking a
compilation target when you compile
there are some little amendments that
you might need to make to the source
code you might need to make to the build
system to make it work
but overall it's pretty simple
there are a couple limitations to keep
in mind as i said webassembly is single
threaded
as of now
certain libraries and certain workflows
might not work depending on what they
need such as controllers or other things
that or the audio for instance
but finally
with great power comes great
responsibility now the power here
is for you to distribute a game over the
web
but when you do that remember to keep
your audience and your users in mind
so when you build when you bundle
try and optimize for the right things
and measure the outcomes see what makes
things good
uh and yeah just make sure that the
experience is as good as possible
now this
is actually all i had but i reckon do we
want to see the game running do you want
to see if we can get it up
yeah let's see if i can get this uh hey
so we're on this
oh
is it going to run is it going to run
it seems my browser is a bit sort of not
really responsive here because
it's not opening its tab
that's interesting
how about we do this
try and open it again
uh
and shift this to
number one
there we go
so super simple breakout clone
and it runs
all right so that's it if there's any
questions
there's coupling back there you i saw
you
first uh
changing the way you allocate might
benefit your site
have you considered trying another
allocation strategy like
arena allocation or something i have not
done this for the specific case but that
is also good yeah like figure out
obviously that looks like anything right
um i don't have much experience with it
but i'm sort of aware of it but yeah
like anything you can do to change it or
to make it more effective or smaller
it's probably good
this one there yeah what is the maximum
resolution
oh that's interesting i've never thought
to check
uh do you
jerk in i i don't know or i don't know
why that doesn't matter i think the it's
the canvas that sort of uh this one
uh wait so resolution
in
what sense like how large can you make
it or
i don't know the the native one runs up
to
4k at least i'm assuming you can make
the cameras larger if you want to i
think this one's 1280 or something
um 1280 by what so 1080
is that
anyway i'm sorry i don't actually know
but it's a good question
right i think yeah
the performance profiling
yeah we can open that just in the
browser here you know how that works
i still have 12.
poop
there we go
all right what were you looking for
performance eh
sure
cool
hey
it's a good shot yeah so it runs from
what i can tell usually around or mostly
at 60 and minimum 26.3 so that's pretty
decent but again i mean this is a very
simple
breakout clone obviously
uh depending on how complicated it gets
it
might not work yeah
so the the large assembly size that you
ended up with yes that's mostly due to
the size of the bevy game engine or is
that how it is when you make your arrest
lessons
that is also a really good question i
don't know
um
[Music]
it's very
thanks
do you want to sort of elaborate on why
it's buffy
all right so for anyone who didn't hear
that it's the game engine because it has
to download and run a whole actual game
engine in your browser and that just
takes a lot of space
so the game here is i think like 100
lines of code or something it's pretty
simple so it's not like that massive but
obviously the game engine and to make it
run
takes a little bit a while
it's a bit choppy uh i don't have
anywhere on the projector it's it
depends on how much i've got running on
my computer as well as with everything
uh but it seems
when i run it on on this screen like
locally it seems perfectly fine
sometimes it might get a bit choppy but
also that depends on your system
as i mentioned this is a linux system
and so it might be that i just
configured the gpu way wrong and things
just don't work as intended i i don't
know like i've used this for a couple
years i still don't know the first thing
about it i try and it usually sort of
works out
this one in the back
um
yes so to just to rewrite the question
is i mentioned that
webassembly is meant to complement
javascript but is is it possible to use
webassembly to sort of i mean control
the web page so you can build web pages
in other languages and not just in
javascript and not just use web74
and the short answer is yes there is uh
so i mentioned earlier that
you you can import javascript functions
you can call dom money you can do dom
manipulation in rust there are
frameworks in rust such as the one i'm
most familiar with is called you which
lets you build essentially like react
or any sort of javascript app it lets
you build the whole thing in rust and
runs in the browser so it is possible i
don't know really what the state of it
is you still need to initialize it from
javascript and so on and so on
but i don't actually know where they're
going with it in the end but
the official stance is always
it's meant to complement javascript not
replace it
but that might mean that javascript does
what it does best which is these little
little sprinkles right and then if you
want to build a whole app maybe that's
better done in something else
all right
anyone else
no all right in which case yeah
yeah so the question is with rusty feels
like there's a lot of
sdks and libraries that are not stable
yet
so what's my experience with it right
yeah and it's true in rust a lot of
libraries are
still in like o point whatever they
haven't quite hit 1.0 any yet
um
in my experience that's usually fine
obviously i did have this thing that
it's been weeks trying to figure out
what was happening right but usually
it's not been an issue i haven't built
any like large scale apps or anything in
rust but i've used it for
a couple of simple like little web apps
or a little server that does this or
that or advent of code and stuff like
that usually fine
and i know rust is used in production a
lot of places and like big places like
amazon and google and stuff and they use
it
so it does work
um
and i would probably say look at what
libraries you can find and if you can't
find a 1.0 just see what it's all about
because usually
even before 1.00 they've been quite
stable in my experience
right
great
ah yes
uh yeah
so what exactly do you mean by
optimizing
across performance the different devices
that people would be using kind of like
when you're making mobile applications
you want a specific experience for
everyone right you don't want it to like
accelerate hardware
ah right
that is
very likely possible
but i also do not know i'm sorry
yes
is
ah that's a good question now there's a
couple things i didn't mention uh and
the question was how do you debug when
you got this massive file sort of
includes everything right so how do you
include how do you debug the compiled
binary or the wise and binary thing
right
and
what we saw with the compilations and
how i compile this when you compile for
was them like the completion takes a
while so it's probably not optimal for
when you're developing
you probably wanted you do this for like
release build
uh and also because the changes you need
to make are so few
when i'd sort of when i was developing
things and trying to make it work i
would build it for native and just run
it on my computer and just debug it that
way
and then just hope it works in the
browser i mean the one thing that we do
change here is the the webgl
or the renderer
that might cause problems but i haven't
run into any so i haven't actually had
to solve that problem
but say try and probably run it for
native first and then if you have to run
for the web there might be ways to do it
but i haven't checked
we had
did you have a question right yeah you
partially answered it now but i was
wondering how the developer experience
was you have to compile the entire thing
yeah every time you make a change
yeah so about that as well bevy has a
feature called dynamic which you can use
which is really useful for development
which lets you
because it will load pretty much
everything dynamically
but just compile bits you change
and so development-wise this is great
because that means it takes like a
second or two to rebuild it's pretty
much instant right you rebuild and you
see it
i did not get that working with the the
the build script that i had for it
wasn't because i didn't really well
because at that point i just accepted
that i'm not going to make a game anyway
i'll just use breakouts i didn't really
need it but when working on the actual
game
using
dynamic to reload is
much much faster and very smooth it's
also uh outlining the docs if you need
how to use it
yeah
do you have one more question
all right see like source map yeah so
you can do source maps to debug things
that's great
all right
any struggles
no all right then thank you very much
for coming along to listening
it's really nice seeing you